une idée venue pendant le premier
confinement la websérie celle confinée a
entièrement été pensé et réalisé et
monté par alex plus de faim en fait au
début j'étais un peu angoissé alors du
premier confinement
je déjà tous mes projets soient arrêtés
donc et en peluche sur un peu
hypocondriaque à mes heures donc j'avais
un peu peur de deux virus donc je me
suis dit il faut que tu te motive avec
un projet en ce moment j'ai envie de
vachement de faire de la réalisation et
de jouer la comédie donc je me suis dit
ben tiens si je faisais une série tout
seul vie mois non-stop pour réaliser
cette série composée de 11 épisodes de
six minutes chacun c'est un huis clos
qui commence par le live d'un chanteur
et puis ça dégénère parce qu'il fait une
chanson humoristique sur le co vide et
il ya un commentaire ou le un mec prend
pas ça bien du tout et le menaçant fait
deux morts donc là ça part en sucette
et puis les mecs se fait enfermer dans
une cave par ce gars et va subir une
batterie de tests qui sont assez
énigmatique pleine de suspense et cette
série parle aussi de liberté
d'expression et d'introspection
ce mec se retrouve tout seul dans cette
cave et du coup il va être amené à
beaucoup réfléchir sur sa vie donc il ya
un esprit un petit peu philosophique
aussi dans la série ou voilà un côté
très thriller où le mec qui est enfermé
un côté réflexion mecs se pose des
questions sur sa vie et se demande
qu'est ce que lui fait ce type en fait
mais réaliser une série qui fait au
total plus d'une heure demande beaucoup
de travail d'autant plus quand on est
seul j'avais comme j'ai quand même ce
bagage technique
j'ai fait les troisièmes satrape l'école
de l'audiovisuel donc j'ai un bagage
technique est là après la difficulté
c'est de faire les choses tout seul
effectivement on met un micro sur perche
pour pouvoir prendre leçon
la caméra c'est pas évident parce que
des fois les loin de nous donc fait pour
faire le point c'est compliqué musicien
et chanteur il a aussi réalisé toutes
les musiques lui même c'était vraiment
un super pro un super défi de réaliser
la musique afin de composer toute la
musique s'il ya quand même une heure 6
ans tous deux programmes donc c'est la
première fois que je fais de la musique
sur autant de doit y avoir au moins
quasiment 50 minutes de musique et donc
du coup c'était avec des thèmes qui
reviennent et c'est donc ça c'était
vraiment une super expérience
la série est disponible sur youtube et
pour savoir si le personnage a réussi à
s'en sortir
il n'ya qu'une seule chose à faire
regarder